[Musique]
hastings
à 8h30
il est temps de saluer une dernière fois
leurs familles thomas pesquet échange
quelques mots avec sa compagne elle le
regarde monter dans la voiture
électrique qui le conduira au pas de tir
et lui adresse ce message dans un truc
de cette capsule en route pour la
station spatiale internationale
l'état consente c'est probablement ce
qui tourne maintenant le fonctionnement
de 2 du premier étage et qui va durer
deux minutes et 37 secondes à 90 km au
dessus du sol
le premier étage de la fusée se détache
suivi quelques minutes plus tard du
deuxième étage
l'équipage confie ses premières
impressions au centre de commandement tu
vois bien on est heureux d'être de
retour dans l'espace et on a hâte de
rejoindre le reste de l'équipe
en arrivant là haut
bonjour tout le monde je suis thomas je
serai votre guide aujourd'hui dans la
capsule dragon
merci d'avoir choisi notre compagnie
doit dire c'est confortable on se sent
en sécurité
tout va bien si vous vous approchez vous
pouvez observer notre vue depuis le
hublot regarder si la caméra peut venir
jusqu'ici
on voit qu'on arrive au dessus de
madagascar mais c'est assez nuageux
l'équipage arrive après 23 heures de vol
ils sont accueillis à bras ouverts
thomas pesquet et ses trois coéquipiers
américains et japonais rejoindre les
sept astronautes déjà présents dans la
station spatiale internationale
onze personnes n'ont plus forcément un
peu à l'étroit pour la photo de groupe
et une brume c'est incroyable d'être ici
à peine le temps de se remettre de son
vol que déjà thomas pesquet va commencer
à travailler un programme chargé
l'attend plus de son expérience qu'il
devra réaliser au cours de ces six mois
en orbite autour de la terre
c'est pas très poétique c'est vrai que
j'ai pas envie de rêver mais vraiment on
a une tâche à réaliser
elon musk veut désormais conquérir la
lune puis mars
thomas pesquet approuve ces choix très
ambitieux c'est vrai qu'il ya un peu en
temps d'avant sûr surtout on y vient
petit peu dans le futur ça va largement
plus loin que ce que la nasa leur avait
demandé parce que construire une capsule
pour envoyer les équipages dans l' iss
c'était un projet de la nasa leur avait
demandé de faire qu'ils ont réussi
brillamment autre objectif faire du
tourisme spatial pour de riches
particuliers une réalité prix du billet
46 millions d'euros décollage sauter à
la fin de l'année un bon d'achat de 5
euros au supermarché de la ville
en contrepartie d'une vaccination la
mesure vise à inciter la population de
saint laurent du maroni à se prémunir
contre la coved 19
une initiative originale qui est
accueillie diversement par la population
vaccinée 5 euros
je tiens pas trop on voit bien du reste
que l'épidémie reste active partout car
en réalité le nombre de contaminations
en france est le plus élevé en europe
sur les deux derniers mois
une situation qui inquiète les
spécialistes le moindre faux pas nous
amènerait à une remontée de ce plateau
donc il faut faire deux choses
diminuer le niveau de ce plateau
maintenir les mesures barrières et bien
sûr l'élément qui est essentiel c'est la
vaccination
regardez j'ai tout prévu à à la demande
du gouvernement
castex m'a confié la seringue
alors j'ai l'astra zeneca vous êtes
traite dans vous donc vous vous avez
suivi tout le monde pas ce qui m'étonne
de vous quand même j'ai suivi la rumeur
plaignez-vous ça fait une pub formidable
pour le voisin on voit ce que c'est
qu'une rumeur allait bon toi
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
à laval ce assez
d'après la dance de pop et meilleur jeu
ce quart de l'histoire que je trouve un
peu terrible enfin me concernant et
concernant la presse en général c'est
que d'un seul coup d'une blague parce
que c'est une blague d'une blague ça
prend des proportions ciel depuis trois
jours je suis pas receler par tout le
monde en disant mais alors est ce que
c'est vrai alors est ce que tu as fait
pas qu as tu commencé d'ailleurs qu'en
plus vous êtes déjà vaccinées bah oui
oui donc vous n'allez pas refaire pour
le bon plaisir de monsieur mais ces
mêmes passages trouve tout c'est
important quoi certains partis
politiques dont le vote le rassemblement
national les jours sur les amalgames là
dessus
robert ménard très rapidement s'il vous
plaît et on avance très rapidement et
bien non mais attendez à ce degré d'
autisme par nos services à ma petite
touche de supports à savoir les
personnes autistes apprécieront nous
amène à ça va aller allez vous faire
voir avec sa nomination aujourd'hui je
suis heureux mais j'espère que vous
aussi des hordes essaye de garder le
moral
c'est heureusement et notre vie
aujourd'hui doit être heureuse même avec
les contraintes mais il faut donner du
sens à la contrainte
on le fait pour protéger les gens qui
nous sont chères et ça ça donne du sens
et ça permet de comprendre que cette
contrainte est utile qu'elle a du sens
et elle me permet d'être heureux on peut
pas sortir après 19 heures au palais au
musée on peut pas aller au cinéma on
peut pas aller au restaurant n'a pas le
droit de faire plus de 10 km par jour
mais on avait un médecin
heureux sur le plateau ce matin m'a
coûté tant mieux pour eux mais on a le
droit d'être heureux y compris par temps
de pandémie moi même je ne me sens pas
malheureux non manceau si et je le dis
souvent c'est plutôt les jeunes gens
d'aujourd'hui dont on est en train de
priver leur jeunesse de liberté de
spontanéité d'amour de rencontre
j'aimerais que vous présentiez vos
excuses à alan rossy
je me sens que si vous venez de dire et
de faire n'est pas convenable très bien
pardo pour ces mots est ce que madame en
question peut entendre pour la troisième
fois que je ne suis pas au rassemblement
national vous avez compris donc est-ce
que ça ça va jusqu'à votre cerveau
malade
yves rénier
oubliable l'interprète du commissaire
moulin pendant plus de 25 ans sur tf1
est mort à 78 ans le comédien devenu
réalisateur a succombé la nuit dernière
à un malaise cardiaque à son domicile